Sabharwal: All right.
Good morning
or good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to "Building
Applications in the Cloud."
Thank you very much
for joining us.
My name is Anil Sabharwal.
I'm a Product Manager
at Google
for the Documents List API.
Bidelman:
And I'm Eric Bidelman.
I work as an engineer
on the Documents List API.
Sabharwal: So over
the next 45 minutes to an hour,
we have a pretty exciting
session for you.
It's pretty jam packed.
We're going to try to
have a nice balance
between looking at some really
cool demonstrations,
as well as doing a bit
of a deep dive
into some actual code samples,
so we'll give you
the best of both worlds.
We're also excited today
to have
a couple of partners with us.
We have Sandosh
from gDocsBar
and Ondrej from Syncplicity,
couple of partners that use
the Google Data APIs,
that'll be here to talk to you
a little bit
about some of the applications
they have
and some
of the exciting releases
that they have coming.
You'll also note here
just at the bottom,
we are using Google Moderator
for this presentation.
For those of you who haven't
used Moderator before,
you can just go
to that link there,
the bit.ly/io-cloud-apps,
and you can actually
just sign in,
and you can put
in a question there,
and people can vote,
and at the end of the session,
we'll have Q & A
for about 10 to 15 minutes.
You're more than welcome
to come up to the microphone
and ask the question live,
or, of course,
we'll look at Moderator
and ask the question,
or answer the questions
that appear on Moderator.
All right, so let's get started.
So let's do a quick poll.
How many people here
have built an application
using one of
the many Google Data APIs?
Great. Excellent.
And how many of you
are familiar specifically
with the Google
Documents List API?
Okay, great. Brilliant.
So the majority of you
have interacted
with the Google Data APIs,
and a small group of you
have also seen
the Documents List API.
Great. So today, basically,
what we wanted to talk about
a little bit is where we've been
and kind of where we're going,
and the opportunity around
Building Applications
in the Cloud.
And I'll talk about that
in a second.
But one of the things
that I know Eric and I love
about Google, and many of you
have probably noticed,
is the pace of innovation.
So if we look at this API
as just an example,
the Google Documents List API.
A year ago, there wasn't
truthfully a lot
that you could do.
We provided some basic use
cases around being able to
download--sorry--
being able to actually retrieve
a list of documents.
We had a limited query model
that allowed you to be able
to find out,
you know, find a document
that matched a title,
or be able to look
for a particular spreadsheet.
We allowed you to upload
documents, presentations,
and spreadsheets,
and we had the ability
to trash documents.
That was it.
That was literally where we were
about 12 months ago.
Well, the good news is
we've come a long way.
So in less than 12 months,
this is a small subset
of the functionality
that we've made available
through our API.
So we now do things
like folder management.
We let you set
account level permissions.
We have metadata
that you can query over.
You have an export servlet,
where you can download documents
in a variety
of different formats,
so you can download
your presentations
in Excel, for example,
or in ODS.
We have an advanced query model
around who, what,
when, where.
Really the ability
to kind of manipulate the data
and get the information
that you really want.
We have the ability for you
to actually edit documents
right there in the cloud
through the append service.
And we have a couple
of new announcements
that we're going to make today
around extending functionality
around things like
revision history and others,
which we'll get to.
We're not going to cover
all of these today.
This is just kind of
a subset again
of the type of functionality
that we've released
in the last 12 months.
We wanted to give you
an impression
of kind of the direction
that we're going.
Now, today's session's
around cloud applications,
and what we really
wanted to talk about
is how organizations
and how users
are building applications
that use
the Google cloud service
as a platform.
As a file system
in the cloud,
as a database in the cloud.
The ability for you
to actually create
a Google document
or a Google spreadsheet
and use that as your database
for building really interesting,
rich applications.
And the ability to,
as an enterprise,
be able to get access
to that data,
manipulate that data,
and manage it in an intelligent
and intuitive way.
So we talked to enterprises
before doing this session,
and we came up
with five particular use cases
that we wanted
to talk about today.
The first is migration.
So how do I get
my information into the cloud,
and then, of course,
how do I get it
back out of the cloud?
And how do I handle
different revisions
as different people are
manipulating the same documents,
how do I make sure
I'm getting the right access
to the right revision?
Sync--this is obviously
a very important problem
that we need
to be able to address
in terms of how do I make sure
that the information
that I have locally
on my machines
or in my local network servers
are up to date
with the information
that I have
living in the cloud?
Querying--so how do I get
access to this information?
How do I find information
that meets
a particular criteria?
Sharing--this is obviously
the big Google Docs
kind of prime benefit
in terms of being able to take
any piece of information
and share it and collaborate it
and edit in real time.
So how do I take advantage
of that?
How do I work
with different people
within the organization?
How do I inter-operate
across different applications?
And for any lawyers
in the crowd,
legal discovery.
Basically, how do I manage
situations
where, perhaps
as an individual,
I can get access
to my information,
but as an organization,
I need to be able
to get access
to information
for all of my users.
So if I'm being--
perhaps in a legal case
or I'm being sued
by an organization,
I need to find
all documents or spreadsheets
or presentations or PDF
within my organization
that meet a certain criteria.
And this is
a really interesting use case
of 2 Legged OAuth,
which we're going to talk about,
which will really let you
almost impersonate
the user to gather
information and data.
So these are the five use cases
that we're going to talk about
in detail today.
Again, nice balance
across demonstrations
as well as some code samples.
But what I'd like to do
is I'd actually like to kick off
with a couple of really cool
partner demonstrations.
And the first one
is from Sandosh,
who I'm going to invite to come
up here to the stage
and give us a nice presentation
on a tool that he's developed
called GDocsBar.
Vasudevan:
Good afternoon, everyone.
Um, first I'd like to thank
Anil and Eric for inviting me.
It's good to be here,
and I'd also like to thank
Manu for collaborating
with me on this project.
Um...
So let's get to the demo.
The idea behind the tool
was to shrink this UI
into a simple,
and yet powerful interface
to kind of, you know,
use Google Documents
in a better way.
So it's a form
of a Firefox extension.
It's a sidebar.
There it is.
So you can actually perform
most of the functions
that you do
on docs.google.com
using this tool.
You could filter
the documents
by various parameters--
own, open, start,
private, hidden.
You can also filter it
by document types,
document presentations,
spreadsheet, PDF.
And like Anil mentioned,
the few use cases
that enterprise users required
or asked for
was to migrate,
how to get documents inside
and how to get documents
outside.
So I'd like to demonstrate,
how do we get documents
into Google Documents?
You could start writing
a new document,
or, you know, you could do
a new presentation
or a spreadsheet.
Let me go ahead
and do a new document.
And you can also upload
documents, say...
And they're
immediately available here.
You can also drag and drop
to the sidebar,
and it automatically
uploads for you.
You could also do a search.
You could search documents
by, let's say--test.
This will actually search for
the contents of any documents.
Unfortunately,
it's not found.
So, uh, you could also do
a query by title.
You can do an exact...
Uh, no.
Let's do it like...
There it is.
And how do we get documents
out of docs.google.com?
You could do an Export, say
"Save As" RTF, Word, or PDF,
and also document type
specified.
So if you go to Excel,
you could save it as PDF,
CSV, or, you know,
Tab Separated Data.
And then you could
start it,
or unstart it
right from gDocsBar.
You could also
browse folders, say...
And you can rename
a document.
You could also do
a move to, you know, folders.
And let's say you're working
on some project
and you want to download that,
you know, various documents
off the project
in just one click,
you could do that.
You could do a search
for documents
that are part of the project,
or you could go to Folders,
do a Select All
and Download.
So...
Um, that's it.
That's a short demo of gDocsBar,
and thanks again.
[audience applauding]
Sabharwal: Great.
Thank you, Sandosh.
The next partner demonstration
that we're gonna do,
I'm gona invite Ondrej
from Syncplicity
to please join me up here.
Sync is always something
that our customers
are asking for us,
and I think Ondrej
and the Syncplicity team
have a great solution,
and I encourage them
to tell us about it today.
Hrebicek: Thank you, Anil.
Sabharwal: Thanks, Ondrej.
Hrebicek: That was
a great demo, Sandosh.
I've been using the gDocsBar
for a couple of days now,
and it's working--
it's working great.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Ondrej.
I work for Syncplicity,
where I'm responsible for
product and API design
and development.
Syncplicity is a start-up
based here in San Francisco,
looking for ways to make it
incredibly easy
for people to share
and access their data.
The basic premise
behind Syncplicity
is that our folders and files
should always be accessible
to us and to those we share
those files and folders with
without even having to think
about it.
And what we have done
at Syncplicity
is built a file
synchronization platform
that's exposed
as a web service
and works together with our
lightweight desktop application
to keep your
and your coworkers computers
in sync.
Um, however, we've also realized
that it's no longer enough
to just have the latest copies
of your documents and photos
instantly synchronized
to every computer.
After all, that's not where
you always need
those documents anymore.
These days its web applications
like Google Docs
that we've come
to increasingly rely on
and where we need
our data just as much,
if not more.
Currently,
Syncplicity synchronizes
hundreds of thousands
of documents
between our users' desktops
and their Google Docs
accounts.
Some use us for two-way backup.
Some use us to take
the opportunity
to explore the online world
of Google Docs.
But perhaps most interestingly,
many use us to help
bridge the divide
between the Microsoft Word
devotees
and the Google Docs enthusiasts
by letting both camps use
the tool they prefer the most.
With Syncplicity, companies
no longer need to choose
between one or the other.
They can have both,
and they can have Syncplicity
take care
of all the complexities
on the back end.
Complexities
like revision control,
conflict resolution,
and multi-machine
synchronization.
So imagine Rachel,
a marketing manager
who works for Syncplicity
and works on documents--
on documents that we
publish to our website
and documents that we publish
together with our service.
Rachel knows
Microsoft Word very well
and enjoys working with it.
At the same time, however,
she needs to share her documents
with other people.
In this case, she needs
to share those documents
with Isaac, our CTO, and
a long-time Google Docs user.
Isaac uses Google Docs
exclusively,
and he'd love to see
all of the documents
he needs to interact with
right there in one place.
So here's what they would do.
So I'll pretend to be Rachel
for a few minutes.
Um, Rachel keeps
all of her documents
right here on her desktop
in a folder called Marketing.
The folder is under
Syncplicity's control,
and there are
two documents in it.
Rachel also recently created
a Google Docs account...
that has a few stock documents
inside of it.
In order to keep
the Marketing folder
and her Google Docs account
in sync,
Rachel needs to link
her Syncplicity accounts
to her Google Docs account.
So let's do that right now.
So Rachel will
log in to Syncplicity.
She'll click
on the Applications tab...
and she'll associate
her Google Docs account
with her Syncplicity account.
She'll grant access
to Syncplicity
to her Google Docs account,
and she'll pick the folder
that she wants to synchronize
between her computer
and her Google Docs account.
In this case,
it is the Marketing folder
that I had mentioned
previously.
At this point, Syncplicity
has recognized the link
between her Syncplicity account
and Google Docs
and begun synchronizing
the two together.
What this means is that
all of the documents
that she has in Google Docs
will sync right down to her PC,
and all the documents on her PC
will sync right back
to Google Docs.
Perhaps most importantly,
those two places
will now be kept in sync
always and all the time.
Any changes she makes
in either place
will be immediately reflected
on the other side.
When Syncplicity's all done,
it lets the user know,
in this case displayed a little
balloon pop-up at the bottom,
and the two stock documents
that we saw on Google Docs
have magically appeared
right on her computer.
Here they are.
Let's now go back
to her Google Docs account
and refresh,
and the two documents
that she had on her PC
are now
in her Google Docs account,
and you can see that they were
uploaded right about now.
The document that she'd
like to share with Isaac,
and get feedback from on,
is called Syncplicity FAQ.
So let's go ahead
and share the document
with Isaac.
Okay, let's log out
of Rachel's account
and log back
into Isaac's account.
And, hopefully, the document
that Rachel shared with him
is right here.
Let's go ahead and open it.
And there it is.
You can see that there's
actually a typo in the document.
No problem.
We can correct that.
So I'm going to close
the document,
and now, being Rachel,
I'm going to go back to my PC,
where I'm spending
most of my time on,
and open the Syncplicity FAQ
document in Word.
Give Word a few minutes
to load up.
It's connecting to the printer.
[audience laughing]
[laughs]
And here it is.
So I'm going to go ahead
and make the change.
I'll change "kwestions"
to "questions."
As soon as Office
lets me in.
What Syncplicity's going to do
as soon as I make the change
and hit Save
is synchronize the document
right back to Rachel's
Syncplicity account.
Um, as soon as it gets there,
it's going to be versioned
and backed up.
Um, a few moments later,
it will then be synced
right back to Google Docs.
Um...and if Office...
if Office let me in--
There we go.
I think I can finally...
can finally edit it.
Slowly, but surely.
Um, and I save the document
and I close it.
At this point,
like I had mentioned before,
the document is being synced
to the cloud,
first through Syncplicity
and then right to Google Docs.
So let's go back to Google Docs,
um, and Isaac's account again.
I'll refresh
and open the document.
Again, you can see
that the document
is now correctly spelled
and everything looks great.
Um, so that's
what Syncplicity does.
This is one of the many things
that we do.
Our website is at
www.syncplicity.com.
Take a look at us.
The whole Syncplicity team
will be available
after the talk
in case you have any questions.
Um, and that's it for me.
Thanks so much.
[audience applauding]
Bidelman: All right.
Hey, everybody.
So let's dive into some code.
So the protocol--
I think a number of you
have probably used--
We have 14 or 15, 16
Google Data APIs
at this point.
The Analytics API
and the Maps Data API
are some of the newer ones
that we just launched,
um, you know, within the month.
But the protocol itself
is fairly straightforward.
We're just going to cover
the basics as a crash course.
For those that are familiar,
this will be quick.
For those that aren't,
you're going to get
a lot of information here.
So it's HTTP,
it's a REST base,
the full CRUD model.
You can read data,
you can also write data.
Um, it extends
the Atom publishing protocol,
so it's just Atom XML,
these are common protocols.
If you're familiar with them
you know,
you can pick up
one of these APIs
and then use the same code,
same similar code
across multiple APIs.
And so what we do
a little differently
is we extend the protocol
by having authentication,
so that's important 'cause
you don't have to roll your own.
You can use AuthSub,
you can use client log-in,
or OAuth,
which is an open standard
for authorizing
access to the web,
We extend the data model.
Here's my nifty laser pointer.
It doesn't work.
You can't see it.
Extended data model,
so "lastModifiedBy"
in the case of Google Docs,
you can see who's modified
and when
they modified the document.
We do batch operations
so you can wrap up, you know,
a bunch of requests
into one single feed,
and then the server
will process that
and send back
a response for you
so you can save
some overhead there.
And then lastly,
you can request responses
from the server
in different formats,
so you don't have to use
Atom XML
if you're not comfortable
with it.
I certainly don't
like XML myself.
So you can do JSON
or JSON-IN-SCRIPT
and provide a callback function
if you're in
a JavaScript environment.
And so that image, I think,
you know,
pretty much explains it all.
You know, we have the cloud,
we have the APIs,
we can make mashups.
We can do Contacts,
Calendar, Docs.
We can do a multimedia app
like Picasa and YouTube.
So the possibilities
are really endless.
So under the hood,
what does it sort of look like?
Um, you know, we're just making
get, puts, deletes,
requests to the server.
In this case, we're requesting
a user's list of documents.
This is
an authenticated request.
You see that
authorization header there.
It's got a Auth/Sub token.
We saw that sort of process
in the Syncplicity demo.
So what you get back,
you get a 200 OK,
and you get a bunch of XML.
At its rawest form, you know,
you have a feed
and then you have
a bunch of entries,
each entry being a document.
And there's
a bunch of metadata there.
We'll take a look
at that in a sec.
So if you don't want to use XML,
if you don't want to use,
you know, HTTP,
you don't have to.
I wouldn't choose to do that.
So we do offer
a number of client libraries,
and there's
sample applications available
so you can get up
and running very quickly.
And they just provide
a higher level API.
They handle some
of the complexities
of the token management
and making the raw calls,
and there's a lot
of great helper functions there.
There's also
a JavaScript client library
that's not up there,
and that's both a read
and write client that you can...
It uses it's
own cross-domain communication.
So the first, um...
First enterprise scenario that
Anil mentioned was migration.
And so this is
an important one.
You're gonna want to sync
your local client
to the cloud, right?
And then you want to be able to
get those documents back out,
those files back out.
And so the Documents List API,
as Anil mentioned,
provides document creation.
You saw that also
in the gDocsBar demo.
You can create documents.
You can create folders,
so you can preserve
the folder hierarchy,
between the two clients,
between the online version
and the offline version.
So just a simple example here.
We're making a post request
to that same documents list URL.
You know, it's authorized.
We'll probably need
an AuthSub token there,
and then we're just creating
a simple Atom entry
and creating a category
that's a folder,
of a type folder,
and then calling it
Example folder.
So if all goes well,
that folder should be created
within our documents list.
Uploading content is
a little more involved, right?
'Cause you're creating
a document the same time
you're actually putting content
into the document,
so this is
a MIME multipart request.
So it's the same process
as before.
You know,
it's an authenticated call.
Same feed: URI.
But instead of just creating
that example document,
we're actually appending
Microsoft Word content there.
And instead of using
the folder category,
we're using a document category.
So fairly straightforward,
same process.
Again, the client libraries
handle all this for you,
so I encourage you
to check them out.
I'm actually
gonna skip this demo
in the interest of time.
We have a lot to cover.
But you saw some
of this export functionality
in the gDocsBar sample.
This is actually contributed
by a third-party developer
on one of our forums.
It's open source.
It uses
our .net client library.
Do check it out.
And basically what it does,
it just allows you
to back up
your entire Google Docs
to your local machine,
and you can specify what type
of export format
you choose
for each different type,
whether it's document,
presentation, spreadsheet.
So, how is that done?
We have an export servlet
that's relatively new,
so you can always, you know,
your files up in the cloud,
but you can
never really get them out,
unless you're viewing them
in Google Docs
or exporting them manually.
So now you can do that
programmatically.
And so the documents
and presentations,
each have
their own export servlet,
and then the spreadsheets
also has its own.
And all you really do is
reference the type of document
and the I.D. of the document
and the format
you want to export in.
And as you can see there,
we have a number
of different formats,
ranging from
the open office formats
to the Microsoft formats
and ZIP, TXT,
what have you.
So sync.
Sync is a hard one.
Um, Syncplicity's
done a great job.
You saw some of that,
and maybe you can ask them
how they did it after this.
But you can imagine setting up
some kind of cron job
or whatnot to back up
your local machine every night.
Um, and just as simple example,
using Python client library,
you know,
that five lines of code,
not including
that import statement there.
So we're setting up
a doc service.
With any
of the client libraries,
you're going to typically set up
a service object,
you're gonna pass it,
you know,
your application's name.
You're going to do some kind
of authentication if needed.
In this case, your documents
are all private,
so you're going to need
to authenticate.
And then you just reference
amedia source--
maybe it's an Apache log
that you're uploading to
your Google Docs every night--
the content type,
and just call one of the helper
functions Upload Document.
So it's literally
that easy,
in, you know,
five or six lines of code here
to back up all your docs.
And in this case,
we're just printing
the document that was uploaded,
its title,
and then the alternate link,
which is the link
to Google Docs,
so you can open that up
in a web browser.
So we have
a more advanced query model
than we used to.
Um, you know, we support
the Google Data standard proto--
Excuse me, the Google Data
standard query model,
which is
q for full-text search,
you can search by title,
by author,
by the updated time stamps,
and start-indexes used
for pagination.
But we also have
some other stuff
that's, you know,
specific to Google Docs.
Here's a few examples.
I hope you can see them.
The first one, you know,
let me just query
all my documents updated
within this minimum time frame,
and then order them by title,
so you can do some kind
of syncing that way.
Query the documents,
maybe store them locally,
and then make modifications,
re-upload them to the cloud.
You know,
you can use category, um...
I'm sorry. I guess you can
sort of see this now.
So you can use category queries.
Give me all my documents
or spreadsheets,
and also documents
or spreadsheets
the user has not viewed,
so you can see that maybe
you upload an HR packet
to your users
using 2 Legged OAuth,
as we'll see in a second,
and see if they've
actually viewed the thing.
So give me all my PDFs
that I own,
and they're also shared
with the domain.
So if you're
in a Google Apps domain,
you can do
some special queries there.
You can query on folders,
you can query on writers.
You know, "Give me the results
in JSON,"
so you don't have to use XML.
So you can do
a bunch of different stuff.
Once your data
is in Google Docs,
you can use the API
to pretty much,
you know, get it out
anytime you want.
So at its basic level,
here's what you get.
You get a list of entries
in a feed
and with a bunch of metadata
for each type of document.
So let's take
a closer look at that.
So we have
special categories, right?
We talked about
that "viewed" category.
So this particular document
has been viewed by the user,
because there's
a "viewed" category.
We know what type it is.
It's a document.
There's
a document category there.
We know
if it's in a folder or not.
In this case it's
in a folder named ChildFolder.
We have the common set
of Google Data links.
The "alternate" link
is the one that we mentioned
that points to Google Docs.
You can open that up
in a web browser.
We have the "self" link
that references
this particular entry.
And then we have
the "edit" links,
which you can use
to actually modify the content,
so the "edit" link being
the one you use to modify it.
Metadata, such as the title--
Excuse me.
"Edit-media" is the one
you use to update content.
Lastly, we have sort of
a section of special attributes
for the Google Docs API.
We have
a particular resource I.D.
You can use that for the export
servlet that we talked about.
You know who's modified
the last document,
when it was last viewed,
these two here.
And there's another one here,
"writersCanInvite,"
so you can--This is analogous
to the Google Docs, um...
When you share a document
as a collaborator,
you can prevent them
from sharing it
with further collaborators,
and so you can prevent that
actually using API now
by setting this
to "true" or "false."
This last one here
is the feedLink
to the ACL feed, and we'll talk
about sharing in a bit.
Before that, we're gonna see
a really cool demo.
So the DocList Manager
was intended
as a sample application.
It's written in Ruby on Rails
You know, it provides
all the Rails/AJAX goodness.
Um, and it uses a colleague's
utility library.
It's all open source.
Those two are URLs there.
And it demonstrates some
of the things we talked about
and we saw in gDocsBar
and Syncplicity.
We have category queries.
We can use the export feed.
It's also a mashup
between calendar--
Excuse me, contacts
and spreadsheets and documents.
So let's pop over there.
Before I do that,
I just want to...
If you haven't seen
Google Code Samples,
I highly recommend it.
It's got all
of our library samples
and all the sources
on the side there.
You can run these.
These are all live samples.
So do check it out,
and the DocList Manager
is indeed there.
So the first thing you do
is authorize this website.
And we'll do that using AuthSub
in the same fashion
you saw in the previous demo.
The user chooses which account.
Looks like I've been logged out.
So the user's presented
with the list of scopes,
the list of APIs
that we'll be accessing,
so we know exactly what
this application's going to do.
We'll grant access,
'cause I do trust it.
So we come back to the page,
and you see I just did
an immediate query
for, you know, my list
of documents that I own,
so I have just two,
unfortunately.
But we can do the same
for spreadsheets.
You know, we can
drill down in folders,
seeing the folder structure
of our documents list.
And so this server shows you
that you can
use the API, uh...
you know, it's very verbose,
so you can literally rewrite
the Google Docs UI if you want.
And so just click
on one of these, you know,
I'm presenting that metadata
we just took a look at.
The doc I.D., the title,
you know,
"last updated" and whatnot.
Um, this preview image here
is actually just using
the export feed.
We're just exporting
as a PNG file
and just presenting that
to the user.
You can also choose
to export this document.
It's not as interesting
as a TXT file,
but you can see it did work.
Here's the alternate link
that'll take us
to Google Docs if I choose.
I did mention
this is a mashup with context,
so it's getting
a little cramped there,
but what I did here
is I just queried the user's,
the sharing permissions
for this particular document,
so I can actually add
user one here as a writer.
So he's there.
So just a great example.
I think this took me probably,
you know, a week or something.
Um, not very much time at all,
and using
the API's functionality,
you really can accomplish a lot.
So we talked about--
Anil mentioned that we'd focus
mainly on
the Documents List API,
but, you know, we wouldn't be
building applications
in the cloud
if we didn't see
some other ones.
In the Contacts API, we just saw
spreadsheets and whatnot.
Um, so Spreadsheets,
actually today,
they have office hours
from 2:00 to 3:00.
I highly recommend going.
They're gonna--
They're actually rolling out
some new APIs today
that you can check out
and learn from them.
It's gonna make it more...
If anybody is familiar
with the Spreadsheets API,
it's going to make more
feel like SQL.
It's got a better query model.
And of course you can use
the Spreadsheets Gadgets API
for those that are familiar,
you can visualize your data
within spreadsheets,
creating a gadget,
which is really cool.
Um, so check that out
2:00 to 3:00 today,
in the Google Data
office hours.
The fourth use case
was sharing in ACLs.
This is the big selling point
of Google Docs, right?
You can collaborate
in the cloud.
You saw in the last sample
that you can...
you can add users
using the API.
So let's explain
sort of how that's done.
There's that feedLink,
which is on every document.
It's the list
of sharing permissions,
and if you just query that,
what you'll get is a list
of the different users
that have been
added to that document.
So what you can do,
you can add--
same thing you can do
in Google Docs, right?
You can add owners,
you can add writers,
collaborators
as they're called,
uh, readers.
If you're
on a Google Apps domain,
you can add everyone
to that domain.
You can share that document
across the domain.
There's batch support
supported in this,
so if you're adding 25 users,
you know,
from a Google IO event
that you just met
and you want to share
this document,
you don't have to do that
one by one.
You can save yourself
a little bit
of bandwidth there.
And lastly there's
that "writersCanInvite" flag
that you can set,
so that you can prevent
even further sharing
of that document.
Maybe you don't want
the collaborator--
You know, you want
the collaborator
to edit the document,
but not necessarily share that
with someone else.
And just as a tip,
you can actually,
instead of querying
the documents list feed,
you can use
a different projection,
which is expand ACL,
and now actually inline
the ACL feed with inside
of the documents list,
so you get all
of that information
that we looked at
in the documents list feed,
but you also get
the ACL information as well.
So that'll save you
a little overhead.
It might be
information overkill,
but just a tip.
So at the very
bare bones level here,
this is what it looks like.
It's just another Atom entry,
if we're doing a get
to that ACL feed.
The two important ones here
are the ACL:roll, right?
And the ACL:scope.
So you know what type
it is,
so it's a user in this case,
a.reader@example.com,
and he's been set,
or she has been set
to be a reader
on this document.
Of course, a writer
would be a writer
and an owner
would be an owner.
And so you can imagine
using this,
you know, looping through
these different ACL entries
for some kind of discovery,
so you can discover documents
that maybe
have been shared outside
of your Google Apps domain.
Maybe they've been shared
with otherguys.com.
So you can
quickly find documents
that you don't want shared
outside of your company.
I'm going to turn it
back over to Anil.
He's going to talk
about 2 Legged OAuth
and discovery.
Sabharwal: Great.
Thanks, sir.
So one of the great things
that you get
with the gData APIs for free
is 2 Legged OAuth,
and basically this allows you
to, as I described earlier,
effectively impersonate
the user.
So imagine a scenario
in your organization
where you have, um...
you have a legal case
where the organization
is going to court
over a situation where
you now need to go and find out
who within your organization
has ever talked
about the company ABC.
Now, you can get
every single one of your users
to go through
and do a query
and find the information,
then pass it to you,
or, with 2 Legged OAuth,
you can actually go in
as the enterprise admin
with the consumer secret key
and be able
to actually go through
every one of those things
just as an administrator.
And it requires
no user intervention.
It doesn't require the users to
actually give that permission.
It allows you just to go in
there and get that information.
And there's
a number of different things
that you can do with it,
as we described.
You can do it to modify
the actual user permissions
across documents.
If someone has gone ahead
and shared a document
that's confidential
outside the domain
and you need to pull that back,
you have the ability
to go in there
and be able
to change those permissions,
be able to see who's looked
at a particular document,
be able to actually add
and update company contacts,
set calendar reminders,
upload documents
into different people's accounts
for induction.
There's a number of use cases
where 2 Legged OAuth
comes into play.
One of the ones
that we often get asked about
on the enterprise side
has to do with legal discovery.
And as an example, we built
a AppEngine application here,
where very quickly and simply,
using the Google
Documents List API,
you actually have the ability
to pull up
an advanced query model,
where you can come in
and you can type in
a series of criteria
that you want to refine
your search based on,
including things like
exact title search
or containing the words,
how it's being shared,
whether it's private,
where it's shared
outside the domain,
who it's shared with,
who the collaborators are,
the dates associated
with that query,
and then, of course, who
particularly owns that query,
so you'll see,
I'll run this query here.
This is just off a sample domain
that we've created
for the purposes
of this demonstration.
And what that's going to do is
it's actually going to through,
and it's going to look
at this individual,
this custodian,
spambox@meviews.com,
and it's going to go in
and try to find
all documents that meet
that person's criteria.
Sorry. I don't think
I pressed that button.
Um, and what will happen is
it will actually appear
here with the information saying
that I've requested it.
Here's the information,
here's the documents
that are returned.
If I show the query
of the detail--
Uh, the details of the query--
I'm sorry--
you can see that I can enter in
some information here.
It returned seven documents.
Here's another query
I ran earlier,
where I actually looked
for the query,
for the keyword "awesome,"
and it returned one document,
and it actually returned me
a Zip file,
which I can just open up,
and you can see what it's done
is it's actually exported
all these documents
into a Zip file.
Um, this is something
that we plan to release
within the API
very shortly,
the ability to export a Zip,
so you can get
a number of different files,
zip them up and return them
all in a single query.
So that will come out shortly.
And you can see that
basically it just pulls up
all of
the associated documents
that met
that query requirement.
So just a really quick way
to use 2 Legged OAuth
to actually go in
and impersonate
any number of users.
And just to kind of look
at how that was done,
the Java--
This was done using AppEngine
and the Java client
specifically,
and you can see it's
literally ten lines of code.
I mean, effectively,
we go in
and extentiate
a class of the OAuth,
we set the domain,
we set the secret key,
we put in the information
across,
who the user is that we're
looking to actually impersonate,
and we run a request,
and you'll see this particular
request is quite simple.
It just goes off and gets
the feed of all the documents
for this particular user
and goes in and does a PrintLine
across all of the titles.
But it's another very simple way
of using 2 Legged OAuth
to be able to go in
and get information,
so that
export-to-Zip functionality
will be coming out soon
as well as information
around revision histories
that we talked
about a little bit earlier.
Now, um, we talked
about a lot of things today,
and I want to end with
a really quick demonstration
before we jump
into questions.
There are a number
of enterprise use cases
that we looked at in terms
of being able to use
the Document List API,
the Spreadsheets API,
the Contacts API,
using them together
to be able to use it
as a platform
for building cloud applications.
And one example of that
that's kind of interesting
and exciting is this company
by the name of OffiSync.
And, effectively,
what they've done is
to help with the
interoperability side of things,
is built an application
that actually loads directly
within Microsoft Office
and allows you to interoperate
with the cloud.
So just
as a quick example here,
I can pull up PowerPoint,
and you'll see here
that I have this ribbon.
So I have, you know, have
my normal Office 2007
information,
but I've got this ribbon here
at the top for OffiSync.
And what I can do is
I can click this Open button
and it'll pull up
my cloud information.
So this going directly
into my Google Docs account
to be able
to pull in that information.
I can search by presentations,
documents, spreadsheets.
I can do queries of information
to be able to find things
that match a particular type
of document
that I'm looking for,
and what this is actually
going to do now
as I open this document,
is it's gonna go out
to the Google Docs cloud,
it's gonna grab
that document,
it's gonna convert it,
and it's gonna bring it
down locally on my machine,
and now I'm living
right here in PowerPoint
with a Google document.
I can hit the Save button.
I can make changes.
I can hit Save.
It's going to go right back up
into the cloud,
and now for those people
within the organization
that are using Google Docs,
they have the ability
to get access to it
directly within
the Docs interface.
We talked about Search,
and the other one that
I just wanted to quickly show
is that I can collaborate
on this,
so I can really quickly say,
here's a document.
Even though I'm in PowerPoint,
I can say that I want to share
this, you know, to me...
whether or not I want to give
myself Read or Write access.
Can hit Save.
Apparently I don't exist.
Bidelman: Everyone
just walked out of here.
Sabharwal: That's right.
Oh, yes, thank you.
Get rid of that.
We'll hit Save.
And we will skip
the sending of the e-mail.
And, basically,
what that's gonna do
is it'll go up to the cloud,
it'll change that document
collaboration information,
and it'll provide me
with Share access
and Write access.
So it's just a nice,
'nother example of ways
in which
you can actually use the API
to interoperate
across applications.
So here, someone using
Microsoft Office
can really easily
and really quickly interoperate
with someone
using Google Docs
all within
their own native applications.
So we've talked about
quite a few things today.
And I guess the most
important message here is...
Now, probably
the big question is,
all right, great,
where do I get resources?
Where do I get information
to be able to learn more?
Bidelman: I'm glad you asked
that question, Anil.
[Anil laughs]
So, as always,
we have a list of,
you know, a bunch of resources.
There's the Documents List API
documentation there.
There's information
on 2 Legged OAuth,
if you're a Google Apps Premier
or EDU user.
We have code samples,
you know,
just numerous code samples
in different languages
to get you started,
and there's a developer forum
if you do get stuck,
so do ask around in there.
So I think for anyone
that asked questions
in Google Moderator,
there's a link,
if you want to ask
some last-minute questions.
Also, feel free to come to mic
so we can hear you on camera.
Sabharwal: We have partners
here as well,
so if you have questions
for gDocsBar
or for Syncplicity,
please go ahead.
We'll bring up
the Moderator.
We know it's lunchtime,
so thank you for coming
to our presentation.
[audience applauding]
Now it's so lonely.
Sabharwal: Any questions?
Bidelman: We'll
also be available up here
if you want to just ask
us directly.
man: I had a quick question.
Sabharwal: Please.
For the Syncplicity guy.
What, uh...
Bidelman:
Do you want to come up?
man: How does your tool handle
images or HTML pages?
Hrebicek: Images embedded
in documents
will sync together
with the document.
man: I'm just talking about
like straight pictures
thrown into the Sync folder.
Hrebicek: I see. They will
not sync to Google Docs.
Not today.
man: But will they sync
to other users
that have
the Syncplicity software?
Hrebicek:
That's exactly right.
So the Syncplicity syncs
across all your computers,
the computers of the people
you're sharing with,
as well as Google Docs
and Facebook, for example.
man: All right. Thank you.
Hrebicek: Thanks.
Bidelman: Ondrej, do you
want to come up on stage
just in case?
You, too, Sandosh?
Sabharwal: Hi.
man: Great session, by the way.
Bidelman: Thank you.
man: Um, is it possible to,
um...
to use the, let's say
the Google Spreadsheet
or Google Docs--Let's say,
for example, Spreadsheet,
in such a way that we...
from within our application
launch the spreadsheet,
have the user edit it,
and then suck the data
back in from the spreadsheet
as the user hits Save?
How would we
go about doing that?
Bidelman: I can answer that.
So, right now,
the only way you can
actually upload content
using the API
is, it's a wholesale,
like, upload.
So it's either--
It's not little chunks.
It's the whole document,
so what you would do
is you'd probably export
the document,
if I have
the question straight,
you would export the document
in question,
you know, you'd make
a local change or something,
and then just re-upload
the whole thing to the cloud.
So the syncing there
is not great unfortunately,
but that's something
that's highly requested
from our users.
man: I'm sorry.
I probably didn't make it clear.
So the question was
that they allow the user
to edit or create
a spreadsheet
within the Google Docs
and just extract the data
out of those tables
and rows into the system,
into a different third-party
system altogether.
Bidelman: So that would be--
So the Google Docs API
is used to create
and manage your documents,
including spreadsheets,
but if you want to actually
get that content
in the spreadsheets,
you use the Spreadsheets API.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Bidelman: Yeah, definitely go
to their session at 2:00.
They'll have
all the answers for you.
Yeah.
man: You had a demo
of an application.
You said it took you
about a week to put it together.
It was kind
of an interesting thing.
I guess what struck me was,
or what I was curious about
was how far up
the learning curve
of the actual API
were you at that point?
Were you already
such a super expert
that one week for you
is a year and one week for me?
[all laughing]
Bidelman: This is
the Ruby on Rails one?
man: I forget exactly
which it was.
Bidelman: So I think the thing
that took me the longest there
was obviously the CSS
and Ajax goodness, right?
Just to make it look
all fancy and pretty.
Um, but, having said that,
you know, we do have
the client libraries,
and we have, you know, great--
pretty great documentation
on how to do, you know,
just about
everything in the APIs,
so you should be able to get
up and running fairly quickly.
You know, we talked
a little bit about the protocol
and sort of the underlying,
you know, what's going on,
but you really don't need
to look at any of that
if you're not interested in it.
I would say, you know,
a great place is
to start off
from the documentation link,
and you could have
a full-fledged app going
in a week definitely.
You don't have to be
a guru at all.
man: Now, one question,
you guys mentioned revision
earlier.
What about deleted documents
in OAuth?
You know, our legal team's
constantly asking,
"Hey, this guy deleted
this document.
"It had this sensitive
information in it,
how do I retrieve it?"
So do tools like Postini,
are you guys going
to extend that
to where we can access
that information
through OAuth
and things like that?
Bidelman: So to answer
your first question,
deleting docs
is absolutely possible today.
We just didn't cover it.
Um, you know, you can create,
update, and delete docs,
using 2 Legged OAuth,
so you can...
If, say, a user creates
a document,
or, you know, I don't know,
shares it outside the domain,
you just want to nuke that,
you absolutely can.
Sabharwal: Yeah,
and then on the Postini side,
I mean, certainly the vision
around Postini
is to be able to provide
that archiving
and be able to have
litigation holds
and give the visibility
and flexibility for enterprises
to be able
to protect that data.
So, yeah, certainly our goal
as an organization
is to find ways to be able
to extrapolate that
across docs, across sites,
across e-mail, and so forth.
man: Now, I heard
of a couple of third-party guys
that had, you know,
written apps against all that.
They've kind of mirrored
the functionality with Postini.
Sabharwal: Mm-hmm.
man: Are you guys gonna,
you know, on the road map,
do you guys know about
when you're thinking
about integrating that
just into the Enterprise,
all the clients?
Sabharwal: It's...
It's difficult to say
from a road map perspective
whether or not that's
gonna happen
through an integration
with third-party partners,
whether that's something
that we're going to develop
ourselves or work
with enterprises,
but, you know, definitely,
it's something
that's on our radars,
something that we need
to resolve,
and we'll have a solution
to market as soon as we can get
kind of the best possible thing
together.
man: Thank you.
Bidelman:
Want to do the Moderator?
Sabharwal: Yeah, we'll do
the Moderator question.
So this probably why everyone
is sticking around.
"Is Google going to release
a 'G drive,'
and is this API
going to support it?"
Um, so the short answer
is that, um...
I can't say.
[laughing]
The longer answer is,
at the end of the day,
Google's mission is to organize
the world's information, right?
To make it
universally accessible.
We recognize
that that information
is beyond documents,
spreadsheets, presentations,
so certainly, you know,
we're working
towards finding ways
to make it easy
for organizations
to be able to share files
of all types, pictures, videos,
documents, spreadsheets,
Zip files, et cetera.
What form
that's going to come in,
all we're gonna have to do
is be able to say stay tuned,
but certainly,
definitely the information--
Sorry, definitely the vision
and the road map
and the plan for Google
is to be able to provide
enterprises and consumers
with a way
to be able to share
and sync that information.
I think that's it
for questions,
so thank you all again
very much for joining us today.
Please enjoy the lunch.
Bidelman: There's office hours
later today,
so do check it out
if you're interested.